*burp* Okay.
[synth sounds in sync with words appearing, followed by explosion sound effect]
MARK: So, this is the, uh, Five Nights at Freddy's Musical set.
MARK: It's still here. (To Peter:) How long have you kept this up for?
PETER (from other room): Uh, almost a year now.
MARK: Why?
PETER: Because we're idiots.
MARK: You could'a taken it down and put it back up!
PETER: Because we're idiots!
(Someone laughs off camera)
MARK: it's like leaving the Christmas tree up for a year straight.
Someone off-screen: I'm doing that now.
NATE: We're, we're here at the set-
MARK: Oh I've already done this with CaptainSparklez, the double-vlog, you can't do it, it's just, you can't pull it off.
MARK: Y'know whatever.
MARK (yelling): (indistinguishable noise) I'M VLOGGING LOUDER! ME VLOG ME AM ME DO!
(Others talking off camera. Most of it is indistinguishable)
MARK: We're trying to figure out pizza situation. And it's not going well.
MARK: And now everyone's suddenly looking at me because I'm vlogging which- everyone is looking at me. (audible inhale)
Someone off camera: Everyone act casual!
(Others make various sounds)
MARK: Anyway. Just vlogging. Don't mind me. Cas' (as in "casual") vlog.
Someone off camera: Heh, "cas' vlog" (laughs)
MARK: How's it goin'?
(Mark and AJ laugh. AJ says something but it's indistinguishable because Mark is laughing over him)
MARK: Everyone's just a lumbering beast as they go around.
(Someone talks off camera; indistinguishable)
MARK (to Nate): Hey. How's that cas' banana?
NATE: Oh this c- it's super cas', man.
MARK: Tha- That's a cas'-
NATE: Nothin'- nothin' to write home about but- so banana.
MARK: You look very cas', I mean, I'll be honest.
MARK(to Peter): Ooh, nice cas' soda. (Someone begins talking in the background)
Peter: Thank you.
MARK: Yeah. Oh, that's a cool cas' shirt.
PETER: Right, right?
MARK: Yeah. Very cas'.
MARK: Some cas' singing going on there.
David: Rock the cas'-bah.
MARK: SHUT THE FU-
(laughter off camera)
(Mark starts smacking his lips)
(People talking off camera)
PETER: Alright, this is good. Uh, oh wait a minute, actually- hmm.. eh...
(Someone off camera says something in a Russian accent)
(Nate makes a low sound while using the fire extinguisher)
AJ: Very professional stance there.
NATE: *Makes another low sound*
NATE: "This is really not as fun as it looks..."
Background Voice #1: "Yeah..."
Background Voice #2: *chuckles* "It looks pretty fun!"
Background #3: "Did Nate finish early?"
"Yeah."
*Snickering in the background*
Background #3: "I knew he'd finish early".
(Mark's making fart noises whenever he "squishes" MatPat's head)
Man in background: *yelling* Leave them alone this is MY resturant!
Man in background: Oh sh***t. PEEEEEN
*Laughing ensues*
(farting noise from mark)
(slithering pbht noise from mark)
MatPat: I don't know about you, but when I'm filming YouTube Videos at two o'clock in the morning
About killing animatronic robots,
I drink
~Diet Coke~
Please give us money.
*a lot of different laughs mixed with "please"*
Look- Look at this. Look at it.
*thousand yard stare* Please.
*everyone erupts in laughter*
This is for you fan girls out there!
*A very extended low groan*
*very quiet* Okay
I'm ashamed.
*someone out of shot* Mark you over shot!
Oh, Alex!
*whole room laughing*
MARK: Good job! *thumbs up*
MARK: Hi! So, yeah, it's been, uh, really busy this week
What you just saw, was us filming, uh, for the 5 Nights at Freddy's musical
with Random Encounters and NateWantsToBattle and also,
MatPat from The Game Theorists, you saw him there.
This is not sponsored by Diet Coke, they would never sponsor us.
So, we've been incredibly busy with that.
If you remember last week, I put out a video called "Markiplier Catches a Pen in his Mouth",
which is the (*thumbs up*) epitome of entertainment that we have on this channel.
That's a whole 'nother story, but that was filmed, uh, in the first session that we were doing
for the Five Night's at Freddy's musical with those guys, that was at NateWantsToBattle's place.
He's a really cool guy! Thank you so much for letting me use your bed...
...that sounds weird, but you'll see what it means in the video when it finally comes out!
So, uh, that, compounded with the Warcraft IRL ((video is called "ALL OUT WAR!!"))
uh, capture the flag thing we were doing with, like, 30 OTHER YOUTUBERS!
It was a HUGE bash! I mean, I mentioned it in a video that I was doing before, but...
It's just nuts! The amount of stuff that has been crammed into this week.
And, uh, that doesn't even count the work that we've been doing on the show
uh, Matt, Ryan and I, I've mentioned this before, but we're working on a show
and the script is basically done, we've just been doing final reviews
before we submit it. And, ALSO, I've been working on a project with Jack and Danny
And we've just been starting on that, and that's an even BIGGER project, than the one I'm working on with Matt and Ryan
So, it's all kind of culminated on this WEEK
And, the most amazing thing, is that throughout all this craziness
And, all of the late nights, and all of the EXTREME amounts of coffee..
...almost lethal doses of caffeine that I've been imbibing,
uh, I've been having...FUN
Like, an UNBELIEVABLE amount of fun, like an incredible amount of motivating FUN!
It's the time of my life because, I've always said this to you guys
and I've always encouraged you guys to try to find this "fire" that motivates you to move forward.
It's this fire that burns in your heart, and it burns so bright
that you wanna wake up, and immediately start working on it, and then you don't wanna fall asleep
because you still have more work to do.
Like, that motivating fire is burning again in my heart, and that's amazing!
Like, it's so cool...
GOD, THAT CLICHE! I need to stop saying that...
...but it's COOL, in that it motivates me to move forward, and it motivates me to be more "creative"--quote, un-quote
"catch-a-pen-in-my-mouth" creative. Like, let's ignore that, but...
Uh, it's like, it motivates me to move forward and work on these big projects and it makes me so excited, to be able to do these things for you guys.
And to be able to these things PERIOD, BECAUSE of you guys.
So, that's why I actively encourage you guys to pursue, your creative side so much.
Because, there's so much untapped potential, that you have yet to see
you're chipping away, at the artist inside of you, and you just need to keep digging, until you see the whole picture
of what you can do
And I'm trying to be, like, y'know, less than inspirational here, but, what- what I- what I'm just trying to get across to you guys,
is, there is potential, in ALL of us.
And I've said it many times before, but know, that I do believe,
that in every single one of you,  there is a creative person.
Or a non-creative person, or a very logical person, depending on how you are and how you look at the universe.
But there's that person inside of you, that you can craft into the person that you want to become.
And, no one is going to hand it to you, no one is going to give it to you, you have to work at that yourself
whether it's an artist under there or, uh, an engineer under there, or an inventor under there, or whatever is under there,
you craft that, into the person that you want to be.
And it's these moments, when you have this fire burning in you and you have the inspiration driving you,
that make you, into that person, quicker!
I know that I tend to get overly excited about these things, but that's just because, I-I'm very passionate about this idea.
That-the idea that that you guys have so much potential in you because, i-i-in me, like I know for a fact that I'm not incredibly talented.
The only thing that I do, is ramble like an idiot, in front of a camera.
But I get so much joy out of this gift that you guys have given me.
Like the gift of this YouTube channel, like the gift of, the opportunity to be an idiot in front of a camera, the opportunity to, to do these amathing--amazing things with amazing people
I just want to get the words out! AAAHHHA
JUST KNOW, that in each, and every one of you, I firmly believe that there is the potential, to do something amazing.
And it just takes time, to find that burning drive that moves you forward.
SO I THINK THAT SUMMARIZES EVERYTHING, I'm not 100% sure but, I'm pretty sure that's everything that I wanted to say.
So thank you everybody SO MUCH for watching.
I will let you know, when these projects FINALLY come out, IN TIME, it's very close.
I keep tantalizingly teasing it, but it is close, and it is amazing, and I am so grateful for the opportunity to be able to do it.
So thank you everybody for watching, and as always, I WILL SEE YOU, in the next video, BUH-BYE!!!